so uh first let's talk about this
awesome screen over here all right
that is a 14 million megapixel led
screen
can we can we play game of thrones can
we play game of thrones
okay well that'll be later alright not
only that is we're not only just on the
ground
or i mean above the ground we are right
next to the canopy too so
this pool is not on the ground this is
several floors up a couple things to
talk about
4 000 capacity so we could fit a lot of
people
in here all right not only are we
talking about that big big led screen
which is
the big thing that oh there we go the
stick look at that hear the sound up
here too
guests that come here can access the
pool for free an
hour earlier than the public six pools
two spas fifteen thousand square feet of
wet space
guys and this will be open from eight
a.m to 11 p.m
listen that sound unbelievable so you
can see the pools down here of course we
have the
stage over one of the pools or two of
the pools
and then the big bar off at the entrance
here and of course
this this is a big big
thing that circa has been pushing for a
long time is their awesome pool up here
the temperature ranges from 78 to 94
degrees depending on the weather of
course
and of course the fifth level pool can
be heated up 104 degrees too so
over to my left over here is not only
where i'm at
great spot but there's also cabanas
behind me here too
where you can rent these cabanas get a
great shot of that awesome screen
and still hit the pools up here too on
this level here too
so we'll have more on what to expect
down here in your full forecast i'm
telling you
kj i'm telling you one of these spots
here these cabanas
are for me and you it's going to be
great when this opens up
reporting live at the stadium swim i'm
tip forensics
kj over